on aura le futur le 1 le 2 le 3 2 plus
grands chefs-d'oeuvre le cheval des
affranchis unis a une chance le 1 le 2
le 3 pales quatre pense que c'est quand
même un pot calice now de coppola
jurassique pas +1 le 2-3 et la nouvelle
version fantastique marlon brando le
plus grand chef d'oeuvre effet américain
il était une fois en amérique
[Musique]
ian jones 2,1 le tu ne crois pas le cas
tous les james bond je les ai tous vus
j'ai préféré c'est roger moore le flegme
anglais tout ça le jour où la terre
s'arrêta de magicien d'oz pascal vinzio
qui cherche à devenir courageux et moi
j'ai pas de courage en haïti
voilà
voilà des 13 premières versions horrible
crime
j'avais peut-être 7 8 ans amityville la
maison du diable parce que je vais
regarder au maroc dans un village et moi
j'habite derrière un cimetière
j'entendais des voies non ne regarde pas
ce fil s'apprennent j'ai su que c'était
mon père qui veut problème ça sachez je
suis incapable
[Musique]
professionnel pas ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
incontestablement cédé dans la mer d'un
[Musique]
dinosaure à moi c'est louis xinhua
c'est le mec qui sait faire sans vouloir
faire rire j'ai une quête d'un petit
cocon qfn du smic plus jeune mon idole
c'est un garçon qui est devenu un ami
qui s'appelle christophe lambert jim
carrey ce plan dit ben stiller dans mary
à tout prix et sans oublier les streep
dans le diable s'habille en prada
[Musique]
moi non une seule possible de l'oréal
laisse les flingues et prend les cadets
nous lie le parrain il nous faut un plus
gros bateau en anglais ça fait une haie
de big boss dans la merde
titanic dicaprio parce que j'ai jamais
fait ça dans une voiture et pour ça même
si le réalisateur du coupé d'un putsch
contre bacula dans son château des
carpathes donc pointus comme ça suçant
le sang des gens j'aimerais bien c'est
ok pour que je serai très bon coup on
comprend à peu près aussi ou si peu ce
que je dis que c'est grâce au slot
[Musique]